(audience applauding and cheering)
- Love this.
- Thank you.
- It's so nice to meet you.
I love everything you do.
But I will tell you,
the thing I've seen you most in is...
- [Kate] Oh, God.
- I'm obsessed with
Shooter. (chuckles)
- That's such a...
- [Kelley] I'm literally...
- Blast from the past.
- I know, but I'm a dude.
Like when it comes to films,
a lot of times, I love action.
And I just had to tell you.
I've literally watched
that film 39 times. Yeah.
- Well it's so weird.
(audience chuckles)
I shot it like a 100 years ago.
- I know.
- And it's on TV all the time.
- And I have seen it.
If you're like who's been
watching this the whole time?
- You!
- It's me.
(audience chuckles)
- Is it true that you
used to be really shy?
That you used to give your
mom notes and not tell her.
You would just give her
notes and not talk about it?
- Yeah. I...
- This is funny.
- I was so shy.
I had a hard time sort of
expressing my needs or my desires.
- Yeah.
- And my mom was the best mom ever,
used to leave me little
notes on my pillow at night
just saying, I love you.
- Yeah.
- Or, you know, good job today at school.
And so I thought, oh
well that's a way that
I can get what I want
- [Kelley] Communicate.
- without speaking to you.
So I used to like slip
things in under her door
at night, you know, I really
want that Barbie or whatever.
And then it became sort
of more complicated.
Like when I turned I think 9,
I would write I really want an agent.
(Kelley and audience laughing)
And she was kind of like,
I have no idea how to get you an agent,
but that's really cute. (chuckling)
- [Kelley] Yeah.
You knew that young?
That's incredible.
- [Kate] Yeah.
- Not everybody has that.
- Well, did you know young?
- Not at 9.
- No, no, no.
- Oh. Okay.
(audience chuckles)
- Like I sang, like in church.
- Yeah.
Like every other human in
my community. (chuckles)
So like it wasn't special, so I didn't.
No I didn't know till I was...
I don't know, like teens.
- [Kate] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- No, I do think it's lucky
to know at a young age.
- [Kelley] Yeah.
- Yeah, for sure.
- And a lot of people
will go through their life
and not, you know, they're
a jack of all trades,
but master of not one
that they really focus on,
that they love.
So it's cool when they,
we find that, that young.
- I do feel, yeah...
I feel lucky that I love it
as much today as I did then.
You know?
- Yeah. Oh, that's special.
- I know.
I feel like when that goes,
people always ask me like do
you think you'll ever retire?
And I'm like whenever I'm tired of it
or if it gets boring.
- [Kate] Yeah. Yeah.
But I still love it.
- [Kate] Yeah.
- So, yeah.
Yeah. Well one of your first acting jobs
was actually a Super Bowl
commercial, so that's elevated.
(audience chuckling)
I was like, that's incredible.
- It was really very exciting.
It's still exciting today to watch it
because I wish I wasn't in a
Super Bowl commercial today.
- [Kelley] I mean, they're huge.
- [Kate] They're huge.
(audience awing)
- Oh yeah.
- [Kelley] Look how cute you are.
- [Kate] I felt like
I was filming a movie.
Like that's how exciting
it was at the time.
- Well, cause it's like the first thing.
- Yeah.
- Were you more excited
about craft services?
Like, (chuckling)
I always feel like every
time I talk to people,
they're always like craft
services was incredible.
- I brought one of our kids here today
and the thing he was most excited
about was the food that
was gonna be around.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- Check out the hallway.
There's a big hallway
full of stuff you won't want him to eat.
- Yeah. (chuckling)
- So you come from a,
a huge football family.
I actually did not know this about you,
but one of your parents owns the Steelers
and one owns the Giants.
- [Kate] Yeah.
(audience chuckling)
- And I'm gonna let that sit for a minute.
Yeah. Cuz' I was like, wait, what?
And then what are football
games like at your house?
Because they get intense at my house.
- [Kate] Yeah.
- And no one owns anything.
You know, we feel like we
do in spirit, but like...
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Literally y'all own them.
So like what kind of chaos
ensues out of football?
- It's pretty wild.
My dad's side of my family,
who are the Giants side of
the family, there's 11 kids.
So my dad is one of 11.
- Wow.
- [Kate] So that's insane anyway.
- Yeah.
- And then they're all psycho Giant fans.
- [Kelley] Yeah.
(audience chuckling)
- So you can imagine how
crazy it is emotionally.
But then I married someone who is
a psycho English football fan.
- [Kelley] Okay.
- So we've got football
on the brain at all times.
- Oh so you means soccer in that sense.
Yeah. Well football.
- [Kate] Yes.
But I can't call it soccer.
- Football.
I know it's called football there.
I just mean...
So that's a lot of sports going
on in the whole household.
- It's a lot.
- [Kelley] Yeah.
- You've sung the national
anthem, so have I,
at an NFL game.
So here's the thing though,
yours was pretty intense.
Yours was an emotional one,
cause it was a connection
to your family, right?
- [Kate] Oh yeah.
I think one of the last...
I don't know why I ever
sang the national anthem.
I was a young, I'm not a singer.
I definitely shouldn't ever...
- I think you are.
- [Kate] No. Like a fun,
I'll sing in the shower
or sing Disney songs.
But my grandpa when he was
alive used to ask me to sing it.
- [Kelley] Yeah.
- And so I thought, well yeah,
I should do that if he asked me.
But now I just can't even.
I don't know how I ever got
the guts to do it because I...
- [Kelley] That's the beautiful thing.
- Again, I don't feel
confident doing that.
- I know, but don't you
wish you could carry that
over into like adulthood?
Like how even in the Voice,
when I have like younger
artists that I'm working with
they don't even know to be
jaded, or scared, or fearful.
- [Kate] Yeah.
- They just go for it.
- [Kate] I know.
- Which is such a way that you
should live your life anyway.
So I love that. I almost wish
we could carry that over.
- I wish. Yeah.
I wish I was as brave now
as I was then for sure.
- [Kelley] Yeah.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping & cheering)
- The new series is called
Class of 09'. (clapping)
- Can you tell us about it? Seems intense.
- Yes.
It is a action thriller that
follows a group of FBI agents
through 3 different time
periods of their lives.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. It's very suspenseful.
- Oh, I'm gonna love it.
- [Kate] Oh, great.
- I love action.
- [Kate] I love it.
- Love that.
- [Kate] Okay good.
- I love all of that.
I love stories like that.
Is it good storytelling?
Like you love the writers?
The cast is pretty cool?
- The cast is so great.
- Yeah.
- Brian Tyree.
- [Kelley] Love. Yeah.
- He was attached to it
before I read the script.
There he is.
- Yeah.
- We just...
We became a family when
we were making the show.
- [Kelley] He's so talented.
- He's so talented. Everyone on it.
We really bonded intensely
over the 7 months
that we shot it.
- That's fun. Well, apart from acting
you also have a passion
for animals, which I love.
So you just posted this, so
where are you in that photo?
- [Kate] Yes. We were in Florida.
I took my daughter to a
sanctuary there called
Save the Chimps.
And it is such an amazing place.
They have hundreds of
chimps that they've rescued
from different scenarios.
A lot of them are from
the entertainment industry
and they... Look at how free...
I mean that's just a giant
sort of playground for them
and that's just one.
- [Kelley] First of all,
I look at that and I'm like,
my kids would want that.
- Yes. And my daughter
wanted to go play on it.
- I was like, monkeys and children.
- [Kate] Yes. Exactly.
- Yeah.
- [Kate] But yeah it's...
- That's magical that
you get to show that kind of experience
to your daughter at like such a young age.
That's cool.
- I know it was her first
time seeing them in person
and she was definitely amazed.
They kept doing crazy
things like, you know,
they would say hi to us
and then they'd run off,
and come back, and spit water at us.
Or they'd bring a stick over
and try and get us to scratch their butts.
That was a big thing.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
- Can you get this for
me? Yeah. (chuckling)
- Yeah. Exactly.
- So I know that Dr. Jane
Goodall is a role model.
So when do you think she
became a role model for you?
When you were young?
- Yeah. My sister and
I, for whatever reason,
when we were kids, I think it started when
someone gave my sister a stuffed animal
that looked very realistic
and it was a chimp.
And we became very
obsessed with them as kids.
And then she and I got
invited to go to Liberia
about 10 years ago to
visit a sanctuary there.
- Yeah.
- And it just changed our lives
and that's when I really got
to know all the amazing things
that Jane Goodall has done for the chimps
and just for our environment in general.
- In general. Yeah.
I agree though, I've been fortunate enough
to where I've been able to do things
and experience things like up close
and personal with just
the most majestic animals.
And you're like, it does something to you,
and not makes you feel
a little in a bad way,
makes you feel so small and
like we're such a part of
something so much bigger.
And it's a beautiful thing.
I think more people should
do things like that.
- [Kate] I agree.
- It's healing as well.
It's very healing and it reminds you that
we are all connected. You know?
That's the biggest thing
that I feel every time
I'm around them, is
that we're all the same
and so we should be treated
equally. Is is my big takeaway
every time I leave a
sanctuary of any kind.